D
BE IN AIFFERENT WORLD.
JOHN RATCLIF, THANK YOU, SIR.
JOE BIDEN TONIGHT CONTINUES TO
SAY NO TO AMERICAN ENERGY AS
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING.
CONTINUES TO SAY NO TO RESRING
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE PURITY WITH
REACTION, FORMER KSTONE XL
PIPELINE WORKER NEIL CRABTREE IS
WITH US ALONGITH OHIO
REPUBLICAN CGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN.
NEIL LET ME START WITH YOU.
YOU HEA THE PREMIER OF ALBERTA
SAY THAT WITHIN A YEAR WE COULD
VE 900,000 BARRELS OF O PUMP
THROUGH THAT PIPELINE A DAY.
W CLOSE ARE WE TO FINISHING UP
PILINE?
>> WE'VE GOT TO REMBER JUST
BECAUSE PRESIDE BIN GETS HIS
OKAY THAT WE ARE STL DEALING
WITH AOMPANY THAT LOST
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS T FIRST
TIME AROUND.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE VERY
HESITANT T COME BACK TO THE
UNITED STATE WITHOUT SOME KIND
OF CONCESSIONS.
IF I WAS AT ENERGY COMPANY I
WOUL SAY HEY, YOU'RE GOING HAVE
TO GIV ME SOME OF MY MONEY BACK
THAT I LOSTHE FIRST TIME
AROUND AND YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
TOIVE ME SOME CONCRETE PROOF
TH WE ARE NOT GOING TO ENDP
IN U.S. COUR AGAIN.
FAR AS BUILDIN THE PIPELINE
HE WE'VE GOT THE WORKFORCE
THAT CAN DO IT.
INBOUT EIGHT MONTHS' TIME, WE
WOULD HAVE THAT PIPELINE UP AND
RUING.
I'M TIRED OF HEARING THAT I
WOULD TAKE THREE YEARS TO DO.
NO, SIR.
>> Sean: I INTERVIEWED OTHER
PIPELINE WORKERS,ND YOU WILL
MAKE PRETTY GOOD MONEY PAIR
THE WERE HIGH PAINKILL
SPECIFICAREER JOBS, RIGHT?
>> YES, SIR.
I TAKE A LOT OF PRIDE IN IT.
IT IS A CAREER.
>> Sean: YOU GUYS ARE WORKING
HARD -- HOW DID YOU FEEL WHEN
YOU HEARD THAT NOT ONLY WAS YOUR
PROJECT CANCELED, BUT ALMOST
SIMULTANEOUSLY A WAIVER WAS
GIVEN TO VDIMIR PUTIN FOR THE
NORTH STREAM TO PIPELINE -- HOW
DID THAT MAKE YOU FEEL
>> WE TAKE A LOT OF PRIDE IN
WHAT WE DO.
I'M NOT TRYIN TO SOUND LIKE A
WIMP HERE, BUT IT BROKOUR
HEARTS.
WE TAKE A LOT OF PRIDE IN
PRODUCING AMERICAN ENERGY.
WE WANT TO DO IT HERE AT HOME
AND LET ME JUST SAY SOMETHING --
I TAKE NO PRIDE AND SAYING WHAT
I'M ABOUT TO SAY RIGHT NOW, BUT
THE PRESIDENT OF THEUNITED STATU
WHENE SAYS THAT HIS POLICIES
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ICES OF ENERGY.
THEY HAVE EVERYTHINGO DO WITH
THE PRICES GOING UP.
AND I'M GLAD YOU HAD CONESSMAN
JIM JORDAN OWITH ME TONIGHT.
HE CAN BACK ME UP ON THIS.
I'VE SET IT IN CONGRESSIONAL
HEARINGS WHERE THEY CALLED EVERY
CEO AND FROM THE MAJOR COMPANIES
IN THIS COUNTRY AND THEY TOLD
THEM THEY ARE GOING TO STOPPRODE
ONLY ONE WHO STOOD UP AND SAID
NO, THIS IS WRONG.
JOE BIDEN, YOUR POLICIES HAVE
ERYTHING TO DO WITH WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
>> Sean: JIM JORDAN --F WE
WOULD OPEN UP THE CHAOSPOTENTIA,
WEST VIRNIA, THAT WOULD BE
HUGE.
LISTENING TO NEIL STORY HERE
AND...
FRKLY, IT MAKES NO SENSE TO
ME.
MAY BILL IT WILL MAKE SENSE TO
YO
>> THIS IS THE GREAT DIVIDE.
YOU'VE GOT THEELITE" AND THE
CRAZY LOVEO THINK THAT THERE'S
NO PROBLEM HAVING FR AND $5
GAS.
AND YOU'VE GOT MIDDLE AMERICA,
WORKING AND MIDDLE-CLASSAMERICAD
WHAT THIS MEANS.
YOU HAD COLBERT'S SAKE, JUST GO
BY A TESLA.
AND PUT A JUDGE SAID TO BUY AND
ELECIC VEHICLE.
E PEOPLE IN AGRICULTURE, THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE THINGS A GROW
THINGS IS WHAT JUST BUZZED ME TO
DEATH.
I REMEMBER WN PETER STRZOK
SAID, I'M IN THE WALMART AND I
CAN SMELL THE TRUMP SUPPORTER'S.
OR WHEN ANDERSON COOPER SAID,
U KNOW, TRUMP SUPPORTER'S --
EY EAT AT THE OLIVE GARDEN AND
STAY AT THE MARRIOTT.
THE DISDAIN OF THE ELITE LOVE TO
HAVE FOR THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHOAKE IT HAPPEN ISWHAT.
WE ARE SEEING ITLAY OUT.
PEOPLE LIKE MR. CRABTREE ARE
WHAT MAKE T COUNTRY SUCH A
SPECIAL PLACE AND THEY ARE
GETTING A R DEAL FRO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: JIM JORDAN, YOU WILL
STAY WITH US.
MR. CRABEE, I AGREE